what do we know about witches the woman
with magical powers and spells in a
pointy hat with a broomstick and a black
cat but behind this stereotype is a long
dark history of torture and
[Music]
persecution much of what we think we
know comes from the 16th and 17th
centuries and especially the work of the
witchfinder Matthew Hopkins it led to
the deaths of around a hundred people
and still has echoes in our lives
today in the 16th and 17th century
people in Europe were living in what
historians call a magical Universe a
realm where it was implicitly accepted
that God and the devil were real life
was hard in England at the time people
were often hungry angry and fearful most
people lived in small rural communities
and between 1530 and 1630 the population
doubled there were plague outbreaks and
a little ice age causing harvests to
fail everyday misfortunes could be
interpreted as either a punishment from
God bad luck or the act of a witch it
was widely believed witches could raise
storms destroy livestock drive people
mad or even kill them Witch Trials
followed legal process and acquit rates
were actually relatively High only 22%
of those tried in southeast England were
executed while burning at the stake was
common across Europe in England witches
were usually hanged in the 1640s during
the chaos of the English Civil War the
Witch Hunter Matthew Hopkins appeared on
the scene along with his associate John
Stern known as the witchfinder general
Hopkins would ride into villages in East
Anglia often invited by concerned
citizens and listen to their suspicions
with his assistance he would search for
The Witch's Mark or te where familiars
were thought to suck blood familiar were
thought to be a witch's companion half
animal half demon they included toads
ferrets and cats he had suspected
witches watched for days to see if their
animal familiar would come to them in
reality this was sleep deprivation
designed to break suspects into
confessing Hopkins also used the
swimming test a suspected witch's toes
and thumbs were tied together and they
were submerged in water it was thought a
witch would float rejected by the pure
water but the innocent would sink women
were considered at the time to be more
vulnerable to Temptation from the devil
some women were particularly vulnerable
to accusations due to a lack of
protection in a patriarchal society and
although most of the witches accused
during the Hopkins Witch Hunt were women
in other parts of Europe greater numbers
of men were persecuted as witches and
men were caught up in the Hopkins Witch
Hunt too the elderly clergyman John Lo's
was accused of Witchcraft in his town of
brandeston in suffk he was examined by
Hopkins who found two teeths on his head
and one beneath his
tongue under torture he confessed to
having six familiars which he' allegedly
ordered to sink a ship killing 14 men
although he later retracted this
confession on the 27th of August 1645 he
was hanged in Barry St
Evans yet opposition to Hopkins Witch
Hunt was growing people began to condemn
his methods
his influence waned and after an illness
he died at home in August
1647 overall around 250 people were
investigated for witchcraft during the
Hopkins witch hat and about a 100 of
these were ultimately
condemned the Hopkins Witch Hunt was a
brief and tragic period in the history
of England many people in the 16th and
17th centuries believed in the necessity
of witch hunts to protect their
communities but these persecutions can
also be seen as a case of blaming
vulnerable people for the difficulties
of the time we live in a very different
world today but has the witch hun
mentality gone away we still have a
tendency to accept easy answers to
complex problems social media fuels both
conspiracy theories and the public
shaming of others fear and uncertainty
is still being used to scapegoat
vulnerable sections of
society so while the context may be
different witch Hance it seems are alive
and
well
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video